E aí
[Música]
que eu sempre sonhei em acampar com os
meus filhos mas a estreia foi um
desastre nosso primeiro acampamento
selvagem acabou no incêndio Florestal de
grandes proporções
Imagina a cena estávamos um lugar
paradisíaco dentro de um parque nacional
no alto de uma serra e totalmente
isolados com um lugar que só se chega a
pé com mochilão nas costas e 5 horas de
caminhada e onde o sinal do celular mais
próximo fica mais uns 20 Km depois que
você chegar até o carro e durante quatro
dias nós ficamos totalmente sozinhos lá
somente Sofia de 9 anos Heitor de 12
minha esposa Débora viu
e visitamos cachoeiras incríveis Subimos
em todos os Picos próximos e seus
meninos a Navegar com bússola a fazer
armadilhas a construir fogueiras a
cozinhar no fogão a lenha improvisado
enfim foi tão legal que discutiram tanto
que pediram para ficar mais 2 dias e aí
a gente teve claro que racionar a comida
para durar um pouco mais
É mas no último dia quando voltávamos de
uma caminhada ao pico mais alto vimos lá
de cima um incêndio na região do nosso
acampamento
é putz perguntei para os meninos Será
que nós fizemos alguma coisa errada
e eles que ela até brancos na hora com
medo de terem sido responsáveis por ter
colocado fogo no parque e ninguém
lembrava de nenhuma falha que poderia
ter causado aquilo como ainda estávamos
muito longe não dava para ter certeza se
o fogo já tinha queimado a nossa barraca
ou não E como nesse momento estávamos
mais próximos da saída do parque do que
o do Acampamento os nossos filhos
queriam abandonar tudo e voltar para o
carro
e as emoções estavam meio misturadas eu
pensando prejuízo de perder os
equipamentos os meninos com medo do
incêndio e minha esposa com dor na
consciência de ter colocado fogo no
parque ecológico
é mas a gente não tinha opção a chave do
carro tava lá dentro da barraca e a
única maneira de voltar para casa era
entrar na região do incêndio tentar
achá-la Mesmo que tivesse toda queimada
é mas aí
e ao longo do caminho não somos vídeos
novos focos de incêndios e um pouco mais
à frente um cara andando rápido parecia
que queria esconder um galão de gasolina
em baixo da jaqueta E aí fui usa partir
para cima dele perguntei o que estava
acontecendo
e ele respondeu que eles estavam fazendo
a queimada que aquelas terras ele eram
dele e ainda me ameaçou dizendo que os
homens dele tava lá embaixo seja lá
perto da nossa barraca colocando fogo em
tudo moral da história
estávamos no meio de um incêndio
criminoso
intimidados por me livros no domingo
quase os crescendo
E como eu tinha que fazer enfrentamos a
situação e continuamos andando até o
acampamento aproveitando que o fogo mas
o plano a direção favorável e quando
chegamos lá quase uma hora depois que
ainda tava bem longe Vimos que o fogo
tava apenas 40 metros de distância da
barraca e que o vento podia vir a
qualquer momento então não tinha tempo a
perder desmontamos tudo o mais rápido
que nós podemos enfiando as coisas na
mochila de qualquer jeito e nos
afastamos o fogo na volta a gente
resolveu pegar uma rota ainda mais longa
para ficar mais longe da fumaça e do
fogo e principalmente para tentar evitar
uma possível emboscada daqueles caras
esse medo do que o que eles homens
podiam fazer foi terrível
E aí nós caminhamos no escuro sem usar
as lanternas totalmente em silêncio por
mais de 5 horas para tentar passar sem
ser visto pelos grileiros que a gente
realmente estava com medo de uma
emboscada que graças a Deus não
aconteceu
nesse dia os meus filhos andaram mais
20km carregaram muito peso sentir um
fome sede frio e muito medo e eles
sabiam que não podiam parar de andar
porque entendiam muito bem os riscos que
a gente correu ali e depois desse
perrengue todo vocês acham que eles
nunca mais quiseram acampar novamente
e como a gente tava de férias o plano
era fazer um novo acampamento na semana
seguinte ver se eles não quiseram ir
tava todo mundo meio de baixo astral com
aquela sensação de que o mundo não é um
lugar confiável e foi preciso um tempo
para eles assimilar em tudo e fazer em
milhares perguntas até esgotar as
alternativas de tudo que poderia
acontecer e quais seriam as nossas
atitudes em cada situação e aí depois
disso nós vimos que eles foram ficando
mais confiantes de que mesmo que se tudo
fosse Pior eles tinham condições de
superar os desafios
e ali eu fique nasce uma coragem
responsável sabe do tipo foi difícil mas
eu dei conta e daria conta até demais é
isso é uma sensação muito boa
mas as pessoas sempre nos perguntam esse
algo muito ruim acontecendo essas
aventuras
e esse é um ponto de tensão eterno Deus
da minha família mesmo entre minha
esposa e eu que concordamos em
praticamente tudo esse Limiar é sempre
conflituoso Qual é o limite entre o
risco e o perigo
e a verdade é que não existe uma
resposta certa para isso é por isso que
a cumplicidade entre os parceiros
precisa ser mais forte do que as dúvidas
Isso inclui as crianças também elas
devem estar cientes do que pode
acontecer para estarem Preparadas Quando
acontecer e de tudo isso que nós
vivenciamos a conclusão que nós chegamos
aqui um incêndio foi a parte mais
simples gerou um desconforto enorme
tivemos que mudar todos os nossos planos
por causa dele mas o risco nesse era
baixo o maior perigo era o que que eles
caras podiam fazer isso é algo que a
gente não tem como controlar
as coisas ruins sempre podem acontecer
por isso que é uma aventura mas o nosso.
Aqui é o outro por quê que nossos pais
acreditamos na ideia de que somos
capazes de proteger os nossos filhos de
todos os perigos do mundo acho que é
esse aqui é o verdadeiro problema
acreditar que nós podemos controlar tudo
é a vida sempre vai trazer surpresas
umas boas outras maravilhosas e algumas
ruins também
aleatoriedade é a única coisa certa na
vida e diante dela nós seremos sempre
Mortais e frágeis
a minha ficha caiu já no nascimento do
nosso primeiro filho na época alguém
havia me dito que ser pai é aprender a
viver com o coração fora do corpo e ele
naquela sala gelada parecia que foi
exatamente isso que eu senti como se o
leitor tivesse nascido de um lado e o
meu coração tivesse pulado para fora do
peito do outro aqui e ele teve um parto
tenso porque ele nasceu pequeno e com
baixo Peso Sem Explicação E foi com o
mínimo necessário para não ter que ficar
internado na incubadora não foi nada
atrás mas foi suficiente para ensinar um
pai recém-nascido o que significava a
fragilidade de viver com coração fora do
peito
bom E desde então minha esposa e eu
fomos percebendo que a vida é muito mais
complexa do que a nossa capacidade
controlá-la E aí direcionamos a criação
dos nossos filhos mais para construção
da Autonomia diante das surpresas do que
para o controle das circunstâncias
entendendo que autonomia não é só fazer
escolhas e ser capaz de se manter
inteiro mesmo quando não houver escolhas
e com pequenas atitudes desde cedo nós
somos tentando ensinar isso para os
nossos filhos Eu já contei para vocês
que o Heitor nasceu com baixo peso e com
a Sofia foi a mesma coisa mais uma
surpresinha do destino
mas eles tiveram a sorte de ter uma mãe
com peitos fartos e disponibilidade para
amamentar regularmente de 3 em 3 horas e
conheço eles cresceram rápido até os 4
meses quando vê a hora da primeira fruta
a primeira aventura gastronômica na vida
deles é a primeira fruta foi banana e
eles adoraram no dia seguinte foi maçã a
Débora nunca gostou muito de maçã e
adivinha só Nem tudo é surpresa eles
também não gostaram E aí o que que nós
fizemos
conversamos com eles explicamos que
naquele dia o que tinha para comer a
maçã se eles não quisessem comer não
tinha problema era só esperar mais três
horas até o horário na próxima mamada e
tá tudo resolvido e o que que eles
fizeram
choraram né com toda a indignação de um
neném com fome e aí o que que nós
fizemos nós conversamos com eles
tranquilamente até que ele se acalmasse
e compreendessem que trocar a comida não
é uma opção que tava aberta para eles e
eles ficaram com fome decidiram ficar
com fome no dia seguinte ou nós
oferecemos a massa novamente e Eles
aceitaram
O que vocês acham que deixar uma criança
sem comida por três horas é muita
maldade
Minha mãe quase morreu só de ouvir essa
história mas os meninos não eles estão
crescendo lá até hoje e bastou apenas
uma aventura gastronômica para eles
entenderem que a vida nos traz surpresas
independem da nossa vontade e começaram
aprender sobre os seus sentimentos esse
e como se comportar diante disso além de
aprender a que experimentar coisas novas
pode ser legal afinal depois da maçã
pode vir um morango jabuticaba desde
então eles são livres para ir para
qualquer lugar do mundo e para casa de
qualquer pessoa e se alimentar sem
restrições o que aprenderam isso desde
cedo
e agora pense no contrário aquela
criança que foi alimentada com a
comidinha que ela gosta todo dia
e no início realizar o capricho da
Criança pode até ser uma forma de
demonstrar carinho mas quando a única
comida que a criança aceita é aquela
isso pode se converter em uma prisão o
que priva a criança e muitas vezes a
família inteira que experimentaram
outras coisas
e quantas famílias vocês conhecem assim
Tá bom eu tô aqui contando uma história
de sucesso como se tudo tivesse
acontecido suavemente
Ah mas isso jamais teria acontecido sem
a parceria Incondicional da minha esposa
eu sou só a Faísca né o cara que inventa
as aventuras e conta as histórias mas
ela que a brasa ela que mandou que nos
mantém Todos estavam ser acolhidos o
tempo todo sem falar que ela é a parte
racional e altamente qualificada para
educar porque estudou E trabalhou com
isso a vida toda então
Obrigado meu bem
oi e ela sabe muito bem que juntos nós
tivemos que comprar muitas brigas pra
educar os nossos filhos para terem essa
liberdade certamente há infinitas formas
fazer isso e você vai encontrar o seu
mas por que que as aventuras são bom
caminho para isso porque elas são
oportunidades de aprendizado de
primeiríssima mão ou seja com a própria
pele mas com riscos relativamente baixos
e fáceis de controlar Muitos pais morrem
de medo da criança ralar o joelho de
quebrar um dedo mas eu quase não vejo
pais preocupados então uma criança
frágil sem energia nem disposição para
tentar nada fora da sua zona de conforto
e o quê que pode ser mais danoso para a
existência de uma criança um joelho
ralado ou sufocamento causado por
acreditar que tudo é perigoso
pensem nas consequências disso
e as consequências de um joelho ralado
são desconfortáveis mas são simples e
quais são as consequências de passar a
infância inteira dos nossos filhos
repetindo para eles não fazer isso que é
perigoso você não vai dar conta de fazer
isso e coisas desse tipo
a falar que tudo é perigoso uma forma de
evitar o desconforto de ter que ajudar a
criança
é mas Pense nas consequências do seu
filho crescer acreditando que tudo é
difícil demais e que tudo está muito
além das possibilidades dele
e quais são as consequências disso
autonomia não é algo que se constrói no
ambiente de superproteção
e
talvez você não tenha percebido mas as
crianças nunca foram tão dependentes de
nossos pais para fazer qualquer coisa
qualquer aventura Quantos são hoje se
você já tem mais de 40 anos como eu Vai
se lembrar de ter brincado na rua no
terreiro da casa da vó sem a supervisão
dos pais ou de uma babá
sozinhos nós podíamos nos aventurar e de
certa forma os nossos pais confiavam que
a gente ia dar conta de fazer isso hoje
nós não deixamos nossos filhos brincarem
sozinho nem nas festinhas de aniversário
tem sempre um monitor lá para garantir
que nada aconteça e consequentemente as
únicas oportunidades que essa garotada
de hoje tem para experimentar coisas
novas e no mundo digital
ali sim eles tem sossego para fazer
coisas longe dos olhos dos pais
sim mas e aí nós vamos nos conformar com
isso
e ao tentar proteger os nossos filhos de
tudo risco estamos criando pessoas
frágeis incapazes de lidar com o
inesperado tanto no mundo externo quanto
no interno eu não quero dizer com isso
que você deve abandonar seus filhos na
floresta como João e Maria para eles
aprenderem a se virar não é isso eu tô
falando de pequenas aventuras
proporcionais o momento de cada um As
Aventuras podem estar em qualquer lugar
experimento por exemplo ir ao shopping e
dar o seu filho sua filha a missão de
seu guia que vai levar a família de
volta para o carro no estacionamento
e claro você primeiro vai ensinar o
senhor entrar para que ele seja capaz de
achar o carro depois mas esteja disposto
a arriscar passar horas com ele
procurando o carro se for necessário mas
desde que ele seja o protagonista
ele vai se sentir o super-herói que
consegue encontrar os carros e depois
ainda pode dar para ele a missão de ser
um ex que vai dar as coordenadas para
levar a família inteira de volta para
casa e novamente ele vai se sentir
melhor do que o ex
e nunca mais vai se perder ao tentar
voltar para casa sozinho
e aliás essa outra linda metáfora do que
que significa ser pai o educador ser
capaz de ensinar o seu filho a se guiar
sozinho em qualquer lugar
Ah pois é para isso que nós somos feitos
para ver os partes sabendo que no fundo
um dia nós não estaremos mais aqui
quando eles retornarem
a educar ensinar andar com as próprias
pernas e ter autonomia
é ser capaz de escolher o melhor caminho
apesar das mudanças podem acontecer
e essa auto-confiança é a única garantia
possível para qualquer aventura e para
vida toda
é porque aventurar-se se abrir para o
mundo e se lançar no inesperado é isso
que transforma pessoas comuns em heróis
As Aventuras um meio de expandir a nossa
percepção daquilo que somos capazes de
fazer e de reconhecer Quais são os
nossos verdadeiros limites
uma forma de aproximar aquilo que somos
daqui podemos ser para que no fim os
nossos filhos possam dizer ao mundo lá
fora e um coração aqui dentro que vem os
desafios eu dou conta não
E aí